Russia's lower house of parliament has
voted to raise the maximum conscription
age from 27 to 30 years old from January
the 1st men will be required to carry
out a full year of military service the
new law will also ban men from leaving
Russian territory from the day they are
officially summoned for Duty
joins us now from Moscow Yulia tell us a
bit more about this conscription effort
how it's going to work and why it's been
expanded
yes indeed the maximum age for men to be
conscripted has been raised from 27 to
30 years it means that starting from
next year the draft age in Russia will
be from 18 to 30 years so all men who
have the Russian citizenship have to
spend one year in the Russian army
within that new age range previously
they were called up for compulsory
military service from 18 to 27 years
meaning that the upper age limit is
increased from the current 27 to 30
years so initially it all started when
the Russian defense Ministry appointed a
proposed rather changing the draft age
last year they were planning to raise
the minimum age as well from 18 to 21
years and the maximum one from 27 to 30
years so now we see that the minimum age
for the Army Remains the Same 18 years
not 21 as they promised so people feel
like they have been cheated and we're
waiting for more reactions to come and
also the state do you increase today the
fines for conscripts if they don't turn
out when they are summoned plus their
adopted amendments to ban conscripts
from leaving Russia from the day these
summons was sent to their work or
university so next step the document
should be approved by the Federation
Council then signed by President
Vladimir Putin yoyo what does this tell
us about Russia's war effort that they
are expanding conscription at this stage
forces don't have enough people Russia
is now wagering its special military
operation Ukraine and no one knows how
long for and when it's going to end
reportedly the latest spring draft was
not quite easy as many young people in
the current conditions wanted to stay as
far away from the Army as possible so
according to some researchers expanding
the age of conscription will increase
the number of conscripts next year from
nearly 7 to more than 9 million people
and it seems like that won't be enough
either because there were reports that
in some Russian cities there were
advertisements in the Uzbek language in
the public transport inviting migrants
to sign a contract with the Russian army
too Julia shop of Oliver reporting from
Moscow thank you Julio
and the Russian Navy says that it has
repelled a Ukrainian drone attack from
the sea the Kremlin says the attempted
strike was on a patrol vessel in its
Black Sea Fleet the Russian defense
Ministry said it happened while its
vessel was monitoring shipping in the
southwest part of the sea the UK says it
has information that Russia is planning
to expand attacks in the Black Sea Rob
McBride is in Odessa with the latest
a week of intensive nighttime attacks on
the port city of Odessa and increasing
concerns here in the city that a
culturally important Heritage sites such
as this one are now falling victim to
this war this is a cathedral right in
the heart of the city that is protected
by UNESCO this was damaged on Sunday
UNESCO has condemned this uh damage also
condemnation coming from President
Vladimir zelensky of Ukraine who's also
been very critical of targeting of
odessa's grain exporting infrastructure
its ability to export food which has
come under increasing attack there's
also been concern about a more recent
attack on grain handling facilities down
near the Danube River and the border
with Romania which is particularly
concerning given the fact that Romania
is a member of NATO
as a gateway to one of the few sea
routes for grain shipments from Ukraine
this remote southwest corner is one of
the country's most strategically
important right now we are invited by
nebulon one of the largest grain
exporters to see its rapidly expanding
facility like most other companies it
used to rely heavily on Main Black Sea
ports such as Odessa heavily targeted
recently by Russia in overnight missile
attacks which also canceled the grain
deal that had guaranteed limited exports
we never expected Russia could be a part
of something that is supportive or like
hopeful for Ukrainian business we will
keep our independence and taken of
decisions and in control on our expert
chain in order to keep our advantages
and be on a strong side the advantage of
these facilities is they feed directly
into the Waters of friendly neighboring
NATO countries grain is loaded onto
vessels here and then sent down the
Danube River the border between Ukraine
and Romania and then out into the Black
Sea except now the ships are in Romanian
territorial water and safe from Russian
attack from less than two percent of
Ukraine's total food exports before the
war there's been a more than tenfold
increase down the Danube
truck driver vyachislav never used to
take this route but is now one of
thousands of drivers coming from all
over the country
I arrived last night and have been
waiting for 24 hours so I can drop off
my grain now
just as Ukrainian soldiers have proved
to be resourceful in adapting to this
war so its farmers and grain exporters
have been equally adept
I really proud and impressed of how
Ukrainian Farmers Traders logistic
companies and Agri industry in general
reacted to New Challenges the Russians
too know the Strategic importance of the
Danube the night before our visit a
drone strike destroyed Port facilities
here
come the next day the trucks were
already lining up again to offload their
cargo Rob McBride Al Jazeera Odessa
region Ukraine